[Music]
what's the last thing you remember Danny
he said we had to route the reason you
survived it's because you're a very
uncommon girl you're not alone not
anymore
do you know what mutants are would
anyone like to shared their first time
brain I was 13 I thought it was a dream
I just lost control
so I started panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend had partnered
Ileana
I killed 18 men one by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out here caller
so we can help you get better I saw
something
I don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your grade it's
prettier and later lived through it
until it kills you he's there we can get
out of this together
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone yes have you ever
experienced anything you'd consider
ignore me
[Music]
yes last question do you know a mutants
are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous than adult ones they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why you're here
[Music]
what is this place haunted house
[Applause]
[Music]
you're being through hot get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]